well the Holiday Rush is about to begin
but many retailers are still looking for
help holiday Staffing is crucial
according to businesses to meet the
customer demand
shopping centers and malls in Las Vegas
are gearing up for the holiday rush in
downtown Summerlin senior Vice President
Andrew sarachi says there is a push to
make sure each store will have enough
staff to meet customer demand you always
continue to keep keep hiring during the
holidays because you never know there's
some transition stirring you always want
overstaffed as the crowds begin to
trickle in businesses are doing what
they can to attract them with sale ads
our team talks to the retailers every
day and the retailers are just just as
excited as we are about the season
coming to downtown Summerlin we've come
back nearly all the way in terms of
total employment here in southern Nevada
uh but in certain sectors that we've not
come fully fully back one of the things
that that's affecting people are trying
to hire Is the participation rate
dropped dramatically UNLV professor of
Economics Stephen Miller says customers
still have extra money from the pandemic
which will help the 6.5 billion dollar
holiday sales estimated by the retail
association of Nevada
for this popular shopping center
businesses are hoping customers will
make their purchases as seamless as
possible and even get a chance to meet
Saint Nick we're going to beat our
all-time traffic record this year over
20 million guests here at downtown
Summerlin and with the parades that we
have every Friday and Saturday and our
revamped Santa Chalet behind me to give
you the machine on that side I mean
there's so many different reasons for
folks to come to downtown Summerlin our
retailers are well aware what that
demand is going to be
all right employers say they are always
looking to grow their staff now if
you're looking to make some extra cash
full time or maybe part-time head over
to our website 8newsnow.com